azerbaijan can lose this match yeah it  looked like okay they might win or it's  going to be a draw and all of a sudden  yeah i i don't understand what if maybe  vassif was just carried away by the fact  that prague spent too much time and he  got too optimistic by the fact i think  or maybe he missed something or  something uh  in in calculations but it seems like a  strange decision to kind of go all in  here  uh considering oh  what  oh my god  oh my god long night blunder look f7  whoa whoa  okay  oh yeah i should i should just never  make stupid statements like this  uh i mean i really thought there was  like zero chance this ever happens but  uh  like 20 seconds ago i said that he will  not do this  yeah you just you just never know yeah  the tension is so high and  and and the point is that the lines